Jennifer Lopez makes a rare comment
about her hubby Ben Affleck's ex
Jennifer Garner the triple threat covers
vogue's December issue and inside she
opens up about the blended family she
shares with then we're super happy on
the topic of raising kids together JLo
makes a rare comment about Ben's ex-wife
Jennifer Garner calling her an amazing
co-parent and notes the actress and Ben
work really well together let me do our
best we can try our best since Jen and
Ben tied the knot over the summer
they've officially become one big family
J.Lo's mom to twins Emmy and Max whom
she shares with ex-husband Marc Anthony
my mom's just like
she's amazing she's such a powerful
human being it's insane and my father
he is
so he's such a loving father and Ben
he's dad to three kids he shares with
Garner Violet Seraphina and Samuel you
can't buy parenting you have to get down
on the floor and play at least a little
bit even if you're a super busy mom or
dad you have to find time for your kids
and when it comes to all the kiddos JLo
tells Vogue their approach to Parenting
involves a lot of love and care quote
they have so many feelings they're teens
but it's going really well so far what I
hope to cultivate with our family is
that his kids have a new ally in me and
my kids have a new ally in him someone
who really loves and cares about them
but can have a different perspective and
help me see things that I can't see with
my kids because I'm so emotionally tied
up it's a juggling act just like any mom
who works it's hard because you feel
that tug in that pool and then you have
these responsibilities and you know it's
a juggling act it's a heartbreaking
little juggling act but seems JLo's got
the whole juggling thing down pat a
source recently told ET that everyone's
getting along very well and they all
feel very unified quote they're really
focused on settling down as a big family
and making sure that everyone is
continually comfortable and happy
they're looking forward to making more
memories together this holiday season
traveling and keeping things low-key
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time as for Jen Garner well the
source says she just wants her kids to
stay smiling which Echoes what another
source told E.T last month she's happy
for Ben and likes that he is so happy
and when it comes down to it the source
said there's no bad blood between the
co-parents
foreign